you are what you consistently do it's a
huge problem for entrepreneurs so let's
fix them if you are a part-time
entrepreneur if you work for someone
else you're part-time entrepreneur you
need to make sure that every single day
you're working on your business you have
to work on your business no matter what
even if it's for 15 minutes at night
every single day you cannot let momentum
die even just to show yourself that you
can't even if it's a crazy long day and
your boss is yelling at you and you come
home and your spouse is angry and your
kids are sick even then you have to
spend 15 minutes on your business half
an hour on your business every single
day you cannot let the momentum die
don't disappoint yourself